an Oscar winner coming into the Vanity
Fair party in the color of the night
come to me for two seconds
congratulation you thank you Oh what is
going through your mind has sunk in yet
hydrating yeah did you practice the
speech did you know what you wanted to
say you seemed like pulled together well
you know what I feel like I just have
the universe looking over me I didn't
want a plan or you know you have
thoughts in your mind and it goes by so
fast
but don't want to jinx anything managing
my expectations letting all the good
energy from just my family friends fans
for the past few months has just been
tremendous everyone was rooting for you
yeah and I felt it yeah now everywhere
you go for the rest of your life people
are going to introduce you as Oscar
winner yeah what does that mean to you
it means welcome to the next step the
next phase you know I've been doing this
for 30 plus years looking forward to
another 30 plus years at least and um
it's gonna look really good we see the
Oscar winner Regina King fabulous and
wearing the color of the night wearing
pink yeah it's been so fabulous to go
through this journey with you from
Toronto to all the way to here it's been
awesome congratulations very happy for
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]